new warning about the risks of
trampoline parks parks very popular with
families a study in the british medical
journal says that kids using trampoline
centers were more than twice as likely
to get hurt and often badly as kids
using a trampoline at home leg injuries
in particular were found to be three
times as common meg oliver has been
reporting on trampoline park safety for
years now and she's with us again meg
good morning good morning to all of you
it's important to know that no one group
is
responsible for regulating trampoline
parks three years ago the international
adventure and trampoline parks
association a trampoline park trade
group told cbs news it would voluntarily
start conducting third party inspections
the group represents about one quarter
of the country's trampoline parks those
inspections still haven't happened and
the group said covet is to blame for the
delay we sat down with a mother in
michigan who said she was injured at a
trampoline park we do want to warn you
some of the visuals in this piece might
be disturbing
that lady was jumping and she i don't
know she's on the ground screaming and
crying right now in may amber warden a
33-year-old mother of two shattered her
lower leg bones jumping at defy
trampoline park in flint michigan you
can hurt yourself like i understand that
you know that's a possibility
um but never
in my wildest dream what i ever thought
that a trampoline could have
the power
to shatter
an adult human leg a new study published
by the british medical journal says
trampoline parks are more dangerous than
your backyard version citing the higher
tensile strength used in commercial
trampoline centers may produce a harder
bounce which amplifies the loading in
bones and ligaments everybody in the
gymnastics community calls them death
parks cbs news has been reporting on the
catastrophic injuries at trampoline park
since 2019. attorney david chason who
does not represent warden has more than
50 clients he says have been severely
injured while jumping at trampoline
parks some alleging these injuries and
legal claims filed against those parks
the boy in the red you know there's an
encouragement here for people to do
flips he's had no gymnastics background
and he's attempting a backflip
and of course it's a disastrous oh and
he lands on his neck
he lands on his neck and
he becomes quadriplegic according to one
expert we interviewed the danger also
lies in the design of the product since
the trampolines are connected waves of
energy are generated in all directions
which can cause a double bounce ending
in high impact collisions what kind of a
risk are parents taking by taking their
children to trampoline parks
well they're risking death they're
risking paralysis and they're risking
a disabling
injury the international adventure and
trampoline parks association declined
cbs news's request for an on camera
interview the organization points out
that not all injuries at the parks occur
on the trampolines in a statement they
called trampoline parks a safe
family-focused environment they also
said the increase in the number of
injuries is related to the increase in
the popularity of indoor trampoline
facilities and not that the trampolines
have an associated increased risk of
injury cbs news has confirmed at least
six people have died from trampoline
park injuries across the country since
2012. that number could be higher
because confidentiality agreements stop
them from speaking out or reporting it
to the consumer product safety
commission i think congress could take
action on it i think the consumer
product safety commission could take
action on it in a letter chasen recently
offered the consumer product safety
commission three ways to improve safety
immediately banning children under the
age of six not allowing flips and
somersaults and removing confidentiality
agreements so more injuries can be
reported you're signing a waiver under
the understanding
that
that it's like a backyard trampoline so
i feel like it's deceitful cbs news
reached out to defy trampoline park for
comment on warden's case and never heard
back warden hopes by sharing her story
it will lead to life-saving changes so i
feel like if this interview can keep
a parent from taking their child and
having this happen to a child because
i'm glad it happened to me and not a kid
you know
i'm sorry
but like i just think about my own kids
and i'm just so glad that it happened to
me not to them
the consumer product safety commission
told us it has not yet reviewed the
british medical journal study we asked
the agency several times if it intends
to conduct its own study on the safety
of trampolines used in parks it did not
respond specifically to that question
but did say it will continue to conduct
incident investigations
so let me get this straight so the
backyard trampolines have standards for
safety that parents can rely on but the
ones that these big parks do not well
what's really interesting here is that
the consumer product safety commission
stepped in to work with the trampoline
the backyard trampoline industry during
the 1990s when injuries skyrocketed and
11 deaths were reported it remains
unclear if they're going to step in here
and conduct their own investigation on
this product as we have seen and we have
confirmed that six people have died from
trampoline park injuries since 2012. if
you're a parent you do want them to step
in because you're just pulling off the
highway wiping the sweat from your brow
getting a diet coke and signing the
waiver you just want the kids to have
fun and you get a break and you want to
see a report like this meg because most
parents are not aware that's why these
parks remain incredibly popular no when
i saw your first report years ago i
thought trampolines are so fun now these
do not seem like isolated incidents no
they don't no i mean the injuries
continue and as we mentioned that with
these confidentiality agreements you
don't know how many more injuries could
be out there we don't know how many more
people may have died from trampoline
park injuries that were released
agreements with a trampoline with any
park of any kind is a red flag already
yeah you're gonna sign one of those you
know and you're gonna be in our park
yeah that's flag meg thank you thank you
meg